اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استووادوا
استووا
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
بسم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وقال الذين كفروا لولا انزل علينا
الملائكه
او نرى ربنا
لقد استكبروا في انفس انفسهم وعتوا عتوا
كبيرا
يوم يرون الملائكه
لا بشرى يومئذ للمجرمين ويقولون حجرا
محجورا
وقدمنا الى ما عملوا من عمل فجعلناه هباء
منثورا
اصحاب الجنه يومئذ خير مستقر واحسن مقيلا
ويوم تشقق السماء بالغمام ونزل الملائكه
تنزيلا
الملك يومئذ الحق للرحمن
وكان يوما على الكافرين عسيرا
ويوم يعض الظالم على يديه يقول يا ليتني
اتخذت مع الرسول سبيلا
يا ويلت ليتني لم اتخذ فلانا خليلا
لقد اضلني عن الذكر بعد اذ جاءني
وكان الشيطان للانسان
خذولا
وقال الرسول يا رب ان قومي اتخذوا هذا
القران مهجورا
وكذلك جعلنا لكل نبي
عدوا من المجرمين
وكفى بربك هاديا ونصيرا
وقال الذين كفروا لولا نزل عليهم القران
جمله واحده
كذلك لنثبت به فؤادك ورتلناه ترتيلا
ولا ياتونك بمثل الا جئناك بالحق واحسن
احسن تفسيرا
الذين يحشرون على وجوههم الى جهنم اولئك
شر مكانا
اولئك شر مكانا واضل سبيلا
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده ده
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب وجعلنا معه اخاه
هارون وزيرا فقلنا اذهبا الى القوم الذين
كذبوا باياتنا فدمرناهم
تدميرا
وقوم نوح لما كذبوا الرسل اغرقناهم
وجعلناهم للناس ايه واعتدنا للظالمين
عذابا اليما
وعادا وثمود واصحاب الرس وقرون
بين ذلك كثيرا
وكلا ضربنا له الامثال وكلا تبرنا تتبيرا
ولقد اتوا على القريه التي امطرت مطر
السوء افلم يكونوا يرونها بل كانوا لا
يرجون نشورا
واذا راوك ان يتخذونك الا هزوا اهد هذا
الذي بعث الله رسولا
ان كاد ليضلنا عن الهتنا لولا ان صبرنا
عليها وسوف يعلمون حين يرون العذاب من اضل
سبيلا
ارايت من اتخذ الهه هواه
افانت تكون عليه وكيلا
ام تحسب ان اكثرهم يسمعون او يعقلون
ان هم الا كالانعام بل هم اضل سبيلا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الحمد لله رحمه اكاديمي
‏stud
in
here and 10 of our studp
and i can very happ tell you out of 10
of them got winners all of them they
were winners so today there was the
ceremony and today we were surprised
with even more good
five of our students
الحمد
الله
‏And then we have the second in the
second place have two of the second
place of the second place and one the
third place. ‏So alam this is very
exciting and the more of happy for us
very surprised
school was picked as number school the
top school top elementary school in the
state
soز this is really exciting
conratulations now if you
allow me the names of the kids
احمد ماء الله
ماء الله
[Silence]
الحمد
الله خير
احمد زبير
ملكغ
الفاتش جزاك الله خير امل
حسين مبروك حسنين
الكباش
المر عبد الرزاق
[Silence]
اشراق الفاتش جزاك اللهير اشراق
‏name
con
schy
[Silence]
ان شاء الله جزاكم الله
ما
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
before
all hisory of
‏building up
his
prophet
ما قيا ما من خلق ادم الى قيام الساعه
فتنه
اعظم من فتنه المسيح الدجال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏until
the hour
comm the day of judg so all
will never
moreجal
[Silence]
المسيح الدجال
نوح عليه
‏propet
was not in their time they
would have to ge
notending
after the death of the prop محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم
why is their
[Silence]
‏all
of
andit
is
nature of isfold
number one what he get his name
‏from
the
put
of beauty a vene of truth over a core
and a substance of falsehood
when we have falsehood but then it is
dressed up as if it is the truth this is
the nature ofجal
‏is techny
any techy
technology that is used to those ends
technology in general is a blessing from
part of what
the human being one of the things that
allowed us to conquer
‏are
of all the creatures on even in divine
revelation to the point that the human
being will receive the revelation and
thein will always be following their
respective messenger from among
humankind
[Silence]
الله
سبحانه وتعالى ولقد كرمنا بني ادم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وجعلنا في ذريته النبوه والكتاب من من
من
ابراهيم عليه السلام
سبحانه وتعالى وجعلنا في ذريتهما
نوح ابراهيم
عليه الصلاه والسلام
عليه السلام
[Silence]
نوح عليه السلام
‏time
bir to
they are all
this is
bestowed upon and techy is one of those
stations techy used
toessch
to
‏kindil
to miracles prophets and messengers
but he imitates the prophets and
messengers with his technology.
‏and some very diical techy
tech will notare
vagewn
parishcept will enter it all with 40
days
techy that will him to cut a man in
head to gr and put him back together and
make
‏techy
that will him to the heavens
that will allow him to bring forth all
of the riches and treasures that the
earth withholds in its belly and for
this reason people will be fooled by a
they will be seduced by him
but this is an interesting point
it is impossible
‏This is why thoseold
underit
are not genin confused
that's why the followers of
notally confused
theyuced yes butuction
‏otheruction
can only the person beinguced
want to beuced they up to that this is
why in the hell the followers of those
tyanical misgided enem of the propets
and messengers their followers will say
فاسقون
معتدون
ظالمون
yes
there wasuced
[Silence]
‏any we have never been moreose
of than we are nowes that he po up
tomorrow or after that time something
new comes we say
‏was
compad
[Silence]
‏a
rectes
‏et on
things that we see on the very often we
are speaking about all of these fit all
of these fit that happen we are
addressing them we just not adding them
as you know this news agency said this
happened and this is the resp to that if
it arises and there a need for that
‏et and view that
truth being spoken about from the
is a place educate
people
andire
‏over
our own backy we do care much however
this is not agency right and the problem
is is that if we
‏things
and vi to
andion
about this is
a person is to have and opion that the
person is to have
then this is exactly what our enem
desire of us to div us
‏based on coned
on conased on
right now if you I all of us right now
not just overas but in the government
overseas would we know how to correct
these problems even if we had the full
picture most of us no so how much more
‏If we don't even have we don't even
know what going and we for a what we see
is propaganda 95%
may maybe 3 or 4% of it is truth and 95%
of it is conjecture opinion and half
truths and misdction
and then the fitna grows within us and
amongst
‏are
well you differ opion
if someone comes opion about
the leader of country i think guy
everybody dislikes
‏How could you
that
can be crossed now are enem
right
to innovation com
it com to com
yougidance inigion of insulting
is accusing
‏you
will someone
to tell us that
the president of Egypt is a good guy no
way if you
the list you are you know you're being
paid for this kind of thing is what is
dividing us that's exactly what the
enemies of Islam and work
‏s
time have
our
other from the blenderal
and moral blender our
we
الله سبحانه وتالى
واطيعوا الله
ورسوله
ولا تنازعوا
فتفشلوا وتذهب ريحكم واصبروا ان الله مع
الصابرين
الله
[Silence]
in die
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه وتالى
‏over any
areem
initeem
الله سبحانه وتالى
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
تراويح جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
بسم
بسم الله
[Silence]
‏Please
take a moment right now and double check
your make they areent we someones
‏we have our
here place
forance
why
and keep your eyes on the in the first
we will have
‏So you watch out forوا
[Silence]
استووا واعتدلوا
الله اكبانه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
الم تر الى ربك كيف مد الظل ولو شاء لجعله
ساكنا ثم جعلنا الشمس عليه دليلا
ثم قبضناه الينا قبضا يسيرا
وهو الذي جعل لكم الليل وهو الذي جعل لكم
الليل لباسا والنوم سباتا وجعل النهار
نشورا
وهو الذي يرسل الرياح بشرا بين يدي رحمته
و
وهو الذي ارسل الرياح بشرا بين يدي رحمته
وانزلنا من السماء ماء
طهورا
لنحيي به بلده
ميتا ونسقيه مما خلقنا انعاما واناسي
كثيرا
ولقد صرفناه بينهم ليذكروا فابى اكثر
الناس الا كفورا
ولو شئنا لبعثنا في كل قريه نذيرا فلا تطع
الكافرين وجاهدهم به جهادا كبيرا
وهو الذي مرج البحرين هذا عذب فرات وهذا
ملح اجاج
وجعل بينهما برزخا وحجرا محجورا
وهو الذي خلق من الماء بشرا فجعله نسبا
وصهرا
وكان ربك قديرا
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا ينفعهم ولا
يضرهم
وكان الكافر على ربه ظهيرا
وما ارسلناك الا مبشرا
ونذيرا
قل ما اسالكم عليه من اجر الا من شاء ان
يتخذ الى ربه سبيلا
وتوكل على الحي الذي لا يموت
وتوكل على الحي الذي لا يموت وسبح بحمده
وكفى به بذنوب عباده خبيرا
الذي خلق خلق السماوات والارض وما بينهما
في سته ايام
ثم استوى على العرش الرحمن
فاسال به خبيرا
واذا قيل لهم اسجدوا للرحمن قالوا وما
الرحمن
قالوا وما الرحمن انسجد لما تامرنا وزاده
نفو
الله اكبر
[Silence]
تبارك الذي جعل في السماء بروجا وجعل فيها
سراجا وقمرا منيرا
وهو الذي جعل الليل والنهار خلفه لمن اراد
ان يذكر
لمن اراد ان يذكر او اراد شكورا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهد اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض هونا
واذا خاطبهم الجاهلون قالوا سلاما
والذين يبيتون لربهم سجدا وقياما
والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف عنا عذاب جهنم
ان عذابها كان غراما
انها ساءت
مستقرا ومقاما
والذين اذا انفقوا لم يسرفوا ولم يقتروا
وكان بين ذلك قواما
والذين لا يدعون مع الله الها اخر ولا
يقتلون
النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق ولا يزنون
ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى اثاما يضاعف له العذاب
يوم القيامه
ويخلد فيه مهانا
الا من تاب وامن وعمل عملا صالحا فاولئك
يبدل الله سيئاتهم حسنات
وكان الله غفورا رحيما
ومن تاب وعمل صالحا فانه يتوب الى الله
متابا والذين لا يشهدون
الزور واذا مروا باللغو مروا كراما
والذين اذا ذكروا بايات ربهم لم يخروا
عليها صما
وعميانا
والذين يقولون ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا
قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين
اماما
اولئك يجزى ون الغرفه بما صبروا ويلقون
فيها تحيه
وسلاما
خالدين فيها حسنت مستقرا
ومقاما
قل ما يعبا بكم ربي لولا دعاؤكم
فقد كذبتم فسوف يكون لزاما
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
طاس س
م
تلك ايات الكتاب المبين لعلك باخعهم نفسك
الا يكونوا مؤمنين
ان نشا ننزل عليهم من السماء
ايه فظلت اعناقهم لها خاضعين
ما ياتيهم من ذكر من الرحمن محدث الا
كانوا عنه معرضين
فقد كذبوا فسياتيهم
انباء ما كانوا به يستهزئون
اولم يروا الى الارض كم انبتنا فيها من كل
زوج كريم
ان في ذلك لايه ايه وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم واذ نادى ربك
موسى ان ائت القوم الظالمين
قوم فرعون الا يتقون
قال رب اني اخاف ان يكذبون
ويضيق صدري ولا ينطلق لساني
فارسل الى هارون
ولهم علي ذنب
فاخاف ان يقتلون
قال كلا فاذهبا باياتنا انا معكم مستمعون
فات يا فرعون فقولا انا رسول رب العالمين
ان ارسل على بني اسرائيل
قال المربنا
ونيدا ولبثت فينا من عمرك سنين وفعلت
فعلتك التي فعلت وانت من الكافرين
قال فعلتها اذا وانا من الضا ضالين
ففررت منكم لما خفتكم فوهب لي ربي حكما
واجعلني من المرسلين
وتلك نعمه تمنها علي ان عبدت بني اسرائيل
قال فرعون وما رب العالمين
قال رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما ان
كنتم موقنين
قال لمن حوله الا تستمعون
قال ربكم وربائكم
الاولين
قال ان رسولكم الذي ارسل اليكم لمجنون
قال رب المشرق والمغرب وما بينهما ان كنتم
تعقلون
قال لئن اتخذت الها غيري لاجعلنك
من المسجونين
قال اولو جئتك بشيء مبين
قال فات به ان كنت من الصادقين
فالقى عصاه
فاذا هي ثعبان مبين ونزع يده فاذا هي
بيضاء للناظرين
قال للملا حوله ان هذا لساحر عليم يريد ان
يخرجكم من ارضكم بسحره
فماذا تامرون
قالوا ارج واخا
وابعث في المدائن
حاشرين
ياتوك بكل سحار عليم فجمع السحره لميقات
يوم معلوم
وقيل للناس هل انتم مجتمعون
لعلنا نتبع السحره ان كانوا هم الغالبين
فلما لما جاء السحره قالوا لفرعون
قالوا قالوا لفرعون اان لنا لاجرا ان كنا
نحن الغالبين
قال نعم وانكم اذا لمن المقربين
قال لهم موسى القوائم
ملقون
فالقوا حبالهم وعصيهم وقالوا بعزه فرعون
انا لنحن الغالبون
فالقى موسى عصاه فاذا هي تلقث ما يافكون
فالقي السحره ساجدين
قالوا امنا
برب العالمين
رب موسى وهارون
قال امنتم له قبل ان اذن لكم انه لكبيركم
الذي علمكم السحر فلسوف تعلمون
لاقطعن
ايديكم وارجلكم
من خلاف
ولاصلبنكم
اجمعين
قالوا لا ضير
انا
الى ربنا منقلبون
نطمع ان يغفر لنا ربنا خطايانا
ان كنا
اول المؤمنين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
واوحينا الى موسى ان اسر بعبادي انكم
متبعون
فارسل فرعون في المدائن حاشرين
ان هؤلاء
لشرذمه
قليلون
وانهم
لنا لغائضون
وانا لجميع حاذرون
فاخرجناه
من جنات
وعيون
وكنوز ومقام كريم
كذلك واورثناها
بني اسرائيل
فاتبعوهم
مشرقين
فلما تراء الجمعان قال اصحاب موسى انا
لمدركون
قال كلا ان معي ربي سيهدين
فاوحينا الى موسى ان اضرب بعصاك البحر
فانفلق
فانفلق فكان كل فرق كالطرد العظيم
وازلفنا ثم الاخرين
وانجينا موسى ومن معه اجمعين
ثم اغرقنا الباقي
ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
ثم اغرقنا الاخرين
ان في ذلك لايه ايه وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم واتل عليهم نبا
ابراهيم
اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما تعبدون
قالوا نعبد اصناما فنظل لها عاكفين
قال هل يسمعونكم اذ تدعون
او ينفعونكم
او يضرون
قالوا بل وجدنا اباءنا كذلك يفعلون
قال افرايتم
ما كنتم تعبدون
انتم واباؤكم
الاقدمون
فانهم عدو لي الا رب العالمين
الذي خلقني فهو يهدين
والذي هو يطعمني ويسقين
واذا مرضت فهو يشفين
والذي يميتني ثم
يحيين
والذي اطمع ان يغفر لي خطيئتي يوم الدين
رب هب لي حكما والحقني بالصالحين
واجعل لي لسان صدق في الاخرين
واجعلني من ورثه جنه
النعيم
واغفر لابي انه كان من الضالين
ولا تخزني يوم يبعثون
يوم لا ينفع مال
ولا بنون
الا من اتى الله بقلب سليم وازلفت الجنه
للمتقين
وبرزت الجحيم للغاوين
وقيل لهم اينما كنتم تعبدون
من دون الله هل ينصرونكم
او ينتصرون
فكبكبوا فيها هم والغاوون
وجنود ابليس اجمعون
قالوا وهم فيها يختصمون
ت الله ان كنا
لفي ضلال مبين اذ نسويكم
برب العالمين
وما ضلنا الا المجرمون
فما لنا من شافعين ولا صديق حميم
فلو ان لنا كره فنكون من المؤمنين
ان في ذلك لايه
وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان
[Silence]
يعني
‏Yes.
[Silence]
السلام
استقيم معتد الاستولا
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
كذبت قوم نوح المرسلين اذ قال لهم اخوهم
نوح الا تتقون
اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله واطيعون
وما اسالكم عليه من اجر
ان اجري الا على رب العالمين
فاتقوا الله واطيعون
قالوا انؤمن لك واتبعك الارذلون
قال قال وما علمي بما كانوا يعملون
ان حسابهم الا على ربي لو تشعرون
وما انا بطارد المؤمنين
ان انا الا نذير نذير مبين
ان انا الا نذير مبين قالوا لئن لم تنتهي
يا نوح لتكونن
من المرجومين
قال رب ان قومي كذبون
فافتح بيني وبينهم فتحا ونجني
ونجني ومن معي من المؤمنين
فانجيناه
ومن معه في الفلك المشحون
واغرق ثم اغرقنا بعد الباقين
ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم المؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم كذبت قوم
كذب عاد المرسلين
كذ كذبت عاد المرسلين
اذ قال لهم اخوهم هود الا تتقون
اني لكم نذير اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا
الله واطيعون
وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجر
الا على رب العالمين
اتبنون بكل ريع ايه تعبثون
وتتخذون
مصانع لعلكم تخلدون
واذا بطشتم بطشتم جبارين
فاتقوا الله واطيعون
واتقوا الذين امدكم
بما تعلمون
امدكم
بانعام
وبنين
وجنات
وعيون
اني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم عظيم
قالوا سواء
علينا اوعثت ام لم تكن من الواعظين
ان هذا الا خلق
الاولين
وما نحن بمعذبين
فكذبوه فاهلكناهم
ان في ذلك لايه
وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
كذبت ثمود المرسلين
اذ قال لهم اخوهم صالح
الا تتقون
اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله واطيعون
وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري الا على
رب العالمين
اتتركون فيما هاهنا امنين
في جنات
وعيون
وزروع ونخل طلعها هضيم
وتنحتون من الجبال بيوتا فارهين
وتنحتون من الجبال بيوتا
فارهين
فاتقوا الله واطيعون
قالوا انما انت من المسحرين
ما انت الا بشر
مثلنا
فات بايه ان كنت من الصادقين
ولا تطيعوا امر المسرفين الذين يفسدون في
الارض ولا يصلحون
قالوا انما انت من المسحرين
ما انت الا بشر مثلنا فات بايه ان كنت من
الصادقين
قال هذه ناقه لها شرب ولكم شرب يوم معلوم
ولا تمسوها بسوء
فياخذكم عذاب يوم عظيم
فعقروها فاصبحوا نادمين
فاخذهم العذاب
ان في ذلك لايه
وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
كذب قوم لوط المرسلين
اذ
كذبت قوم لوط المرسلين
اذ قال لهم اخوهم لوط ولا تتقون
اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله واطيعوني
وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري الا على
رب العالمين
اتاتون الذكران من العالمين
وتذرون ما خلق لكم ربكم من ازواجكم
بل انتم قوم عادون
قالوا لئن لم تنته يا لوط لتكونن
من المخرجين
قال اني لعملكم من القليل
رب نجني واهلي مما يعملون
فانجيناه
واهله اجمعين
الا عج عجوزا في الغابرين
ودمرنا
ثم دمرنا الاخرين
وامطرنا عليهم مطرا فساء
مطر المنذرين
ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
كذب اصحاب الايكه المرسلين
اذ قال لهم شعيب الا تتقون
اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله واطيعون
وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري الا على
رب العالمين
خوفوا الكيل ولا تكونوا من المخسرين
وزنوا بالقسطاس المستقيم
ولا تبخسوا الناس اشياءهم
ولا تعثوا في الارض مفسدين
واتقوا الذي خلقكم والجبله الاولين
قالوا انما انت من المسحرين
وما انت الا بشر مثلنا
وان نظنك لمن الكاذبين
فاسقط علينا كسفا من السماء ان كنت من
الصادقين
قال ربي اعلم بما تعملون
فاخذهم عذاب يوم الظله
فكذبوه فاخذهم عذاب يوم الذله انه كان
عذاب يوم عظيم
ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
وانه لتنزيل رب العالمين
نزل به الروح الامين على قلبك لتكون من
المنذرين
بلسان عرب مبين وانه لفي زبر الاولين
اولم يكن لهم ايه ان يعلمه علماء ماء
بني اسرائيل
ولو نزلناه على بعض الاعجم اعجمين فقراه
عليهم فقراه عليهم فما كانوا به ليؤمنون
كذلك سلكناه في قلوب المجرمين
لا يؤمنون به حتى يروا العذاب الاليم
فياخذهم بغته وهم لا يشعرون
فيقولوا هل نحن منظرون
افبعذابنا
يستعجلون
افرايت ان متعناهم سنين
ثم جاءهم
ما كانوا يوعدون
ما اغنى
ما كانوا يمتعون
وما اهلكنا من قريه الا منذرون
ذكرى وما كنا ظالمين
وما تنزلت به الشياطين وما ينبغي لهم وما
يستطيعون
انهم عن السمع لمعزولون
فلا تدع مع الله الها اخر فتكون من
المعذبين
وانذر عشيرتك الاقربين
واخفض جناحك لمن اتبعك من المؤمنين
فان عصوك فقل اني بريء
مما تعملون
وتوكل على العزيز الرحيم
الذي يراك حين تقوم
وتقلبك في الساجدين
انه
هو السميع العليم
هل انبئكم على من تنزل الشياطين
تنزل على كل افاك اثيم
يلقون السمع واك اكثرهم كاذبون
والشعراء
يتبعهم
الغاوون
الم تر انهم في كل واد يهيمون
وانهم
يقولون ما لا يفعلون
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات وذكروا
الله كثيرا
وذكروا الله كثيرا وانتصروا من بعد ما
ظلموا
وسيعلم الذين ظلموا اي منقلب
ينقلبون
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
طا سين
تلك ايات القران وكتاب مبين
هدى وبشرى للمؤمنين
الذين يقيمون
الصلاه ويؤتون الزكاه وهم بالاخره هم
يوقنون
ان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
زينا
لهم اعمالهم فهم يعمهون
اولئك
الذين لهم سوء
العذاب
وهم في الاخره هم الاخسرون
وانك لتلقى القران من لدن حكيم عليم
اذ قال موسى لاهله اني انست نارا
ساتيكم
منها بخبر او اتيكم بشهاب
لعلكم تسطلون
فلما جاءها
نودي انبورك
من في النار ومن حولها
وسبحان الله رب العالمين
يا موسى انه
انا الله العزيز الحكيم
والق عصاك
فلما
راها تهتز كانها
جان
ولا مدبرا
ولا مدبرا ولم يعقب
يا موسى لا تخف انه
لا يخاف لدي المر مرسلون
اني لا يخاف لدي المرسلون
الا من ظلم ثم بدل حسنا بعد سوء
فاني غفور رحيم
وادخل يدك في جيبك تخرج بيضاء
من غير سوء
في تسع ايات الى فرعون وقومه
انهم
كانوا قوما فاسقين
فلما جاءتهم
اياتنا مبصره
جح ظلموا
فلما جاءتهم
اياتنا مبصر صره قالوا هذا سحر مبين
وجحدوا بها واستيقنتها
انفسهم
ظلما وعلوا
فانظر كيف كان عاقبه المفسدين
ولقد اتينا داوود وسليمان علما
وقال الحمد لله الذي فضلنا على كثير من
عباده المؤمنين
وورث سليمان داوود وقال يا ايها
الناس علمنا
علمنا منطق الطير واوتينا من كل شيء
ان هذا لهو هو الفضل المبين
وحشر لسليمان جنوده من الجن والانس والطير
فهم يوزعون
حتى اذا اتوا على وادي النمل قالت نملا
قالت نمله يا ايها النمل ادخلوا مساكنكم
لا يحطم
كم سليمان وجنوده
وهم لا يشعرون
فتبسم ضاحكا من قولها
وقال رب اوزعني ان اشكر نعمتك التي انعمت
علي وعلى والدي
وان اعمل صالحا
ترضاه
وادخلني برحمتك في عبادك الصالحين
وتفقد الطير فقال ما لي لا ارى الهدهد ام
كان من الغائبين
لاعذبنه
عذابا شديدا او لاذبحنه
او لياتيني
بسلطان
مبين
فمكث غير بعيد فقال احط بما لم تحط به
وجئتك من سبا بنبا يقين
اني وجدت امراه تملكهم واوتيت من كل شيء
ولها
عرش عظيم
وجدتها وقومها يسجدون للشمس من دون الله
وزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فصدهم عن السبيل
فهم لا يهتدون
فهم لا يهتدون الا يسجدوا لله الذي يخرج
الخبر في السماوات والارض ويعلم ما تخفون
وما تعلنون
الله لا
اله الا هو
رب العرش العظيم
الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
قال سننظر
اصدقت ام كنت من الكاذبين
اذهب بكتابي هذا فالقه اليهم ثم تولى عنهم
ثم تولى عنهم فانظر ماذا يرجعون
قالت يا ايها الملا اني القي الي كتاب
كريم
انه من سليمان
انه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وانه من سليمان وانه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
الا تعلوا علي واتوني مسلمين
قالت يا ايها الملا افتوني في امري
ما كنت قاط قاطعه امرا حتى تشهدون
قالوا نحن اولو قوه
والو باس شديد والامر اليك
والامر اليك فانظري ماذا تامرين
قالت ان الملوك اذا دخلوا قريه افسدوها
وجعلوا
اعزه اهلها اذله
وكذلك يفعلون
واني مرسله اليهم بهديه
فناظره
بما يرجع المرسلون
فلما جاء
سليمان قال اتمدونني
بمال
فما اتاني الله خير مما اتاكم
بل انتم
بهديتكم
تفرحون
ارجع اليهم فلناتينهم
بجنود لا قبل لهم بها
ولنخرج فلنخرجنهم
منها اذله
اذله
وهم صاغرون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قال يا ايها الملا ايكم ياتيني بعرشها قبل
ان ياتوني مسلمين
قال عفريت من الجن انا اتيك
به قبل ان تقوم من مقامك
واني عليه لقوي امين
قال الذي عنده علم من الكتاب انا اتيك به
قبل ان يرتد اليك طرفك
فلما راه مستقرا عنده قال هذا من فضل ربي
قال هذا من فضل ربي ليبلوني ااشكر ام اكفر
فمن شكر فانما يشكر لنفسه ومن كفر فان ربي
غني كريم
قال نكروا لها عرشها ننظر اتهتدي
ام تكون من الذين لا يهتدون
فلما
جاءت
قيل اهكذا عرشك قالت كانه
هو واوتينا العلم من قبلها وكنا
مسلمين
وصدها ما كانت تعبد من دون الله انها كانت
من قوم كافرين
قيل لا ادخل الصرح فلما راته حسبته لجه
وكشفت عن ساقيها
قال انه صرح ممرد
من قوارير
قالت رب اني ظلمت نفسي واسلمت مع سليمان
لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
يا رب
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
الهاكم التكاثر
حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترن
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
ان
الانسان
لفي خسر
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات وتواصوا
بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر بسم بس
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن
كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن من توليت
وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تبارك باركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امائك
نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا
قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
او انزلته
في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اجعل القران ربيع
قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
ربنا
اجعل القران شافعا مشفعا لنا ولا تجعله
حجه علينا
واجعله حجه لنا انسنا به اناء الليل واناء
النهار
ورتب به السنتنا
وطهر به قلوبنا
وباعد بيننا وبين خطايانا به اللهم
اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبا عبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك
غير مفتونين
فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
ربنا
اننا
نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
النصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في غزه
وفلسطين
وفي كل مكان حيث حلوا من قاتل لتكون كلمتك
هي العليا
اللهم انصرهم على من عاداهم
واجعل ثارهم على من ظلمهم
واجعلهم على عدوهم ظاهرين
قاهرين
عالين
منصورين
اللهم اجبر كسراهم
اللهم اللهم داوي جرحاهم
واشف مرضاهم
وارحم امواتهم
وانصر احيائهم
اللهم انزل السكينه والطمئنين
في قلوبهم
والسلوى يا رب العالمين
وكن معهم احرسهم بعينك التي لا تنام
وامكر لهم ولا عليهم اللهم عليك بهذا
الكيان الصهيون اللعين
اللهم
زلزل اركانا اللهم
صدع بنيانا
اللهم اقتل اجنادا اللهم اقذف الرعب
والهلع والفزع في قلوبهم
اللهم اضرب عليهم الذل والهوان
واجعل قتلاهم في النيران
وبشرهم بكل سوء
وهوان
يا منان
يا ذا الجمن والعطاء
يا عزيز يا جبار
واجعل قتلا في الجنان
شهداء
عندك
اللهم
صل وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام
على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
السلام
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
ما شاء